i will yup definitely
okay it's being recorded i
believe
yes it is okay let me officially start
okay
welcome to the ddps seminar everyone
before we introduce our invited speaker
let's go over some rules and logistics
first of all please mute yourself during
the talk unless you have questions
if you have questions you are welcome to
admit and ask otherwise please use chat
room to post your questions so that we
can address them in q a session at the
end
second today's ddps seminar is open to
external audiences therefore no
classified discussion is allowed so
please watch out finally the talk today
will be recorded and uploaded in our
youtube channel
that's about it now let me introduce our
speaker today
it is an honor to host michael mahoney
who is a professor at the university of
california at berkeley in the department
of statistics and
at the international computer science
institute icsi
is also an amazon scholar as well as a
faculty scientist at the lawrence
berkeley national laboratory he works on
algorithmic and statistical aspects of
modern large-scale data analysis
much of his in
his recent research has focused on
large-scale
um
machine learning including randomized
matrix algorithms and randomized
numerical linear algebra geometric
network analysis tools for structural
extraction in large info informatics
graphs
scalable implicit regularization methods
computational methods for neural network
analysis physics informed machine and
learning and application in
genetics and astronomy medical imaging
social network analysis and internet
internet data analysis
as you can hear pretty much everything
he touched on
he received his phd from yale university
with a dissertation in computational
statist statistical mechanics and he has
worked and taught at yale university in
the mathematics department
at yahoo research and at stanford
university in the mathematics department
among other things he is on the national
advisory committee of the statistical
and applied mathematical sciences
institutes
he was on the national research
council's committee on the analysis of
massive data
he co-organized the simon's institute's
fall 2013 and 2008-18 programs on the
foundations of the data science
and there are many
awards he
he got and more information is available
at his web page
okay today michael will talk about
toward combining principled scientific
models and principle machine learning
methods which is very interesting topics
so please enjoy and expect a wonderful
talk now without further ado let me pass
the button
michael by asking one random question as
usual today's random question is what is
your favorite things to do other than
research
what's the favorite thing to do other
than research
um that's a good question and i'll tell
you something that i haven't been able
to do in a number of years but um so i i
don't wouldn't say i did a lot but i did
it a number of times and i enjoy it and
i hope at some point to get back to it
i like to go scuba diving
oh wow and occasionally people say oh i
do that i do snorkeling and and and in a
sort of um teasing way i say the only
reason you like snorkeling is because
you've never done scuba diving
i mean they seem to me qualitatively
different and i'm not sure why it just
seems very sort of
i like the beach but not i mean the
beach is okay but then you get sand in
your shoes and it's a little messy but
you know going into the different world
we're underground underwater and so on
um it seems very uh
um otherworldly so um i'll do a thumbs
up for scuba diving how about that
that's great uh sounds dangerous though
so um scuba diving i mean like a lot of
things that driving a car is dangerous
right um
if if you if you know nothing it can be
but um
i took a class actually a a fun fact
before it begins was mentioned that i
was my phd was in computational
statistical mechanics
after that i moved to theoretical
computer science and large scale
statistical data analysis
and worked on that for a number of years
and now in the last couple years gone
back and looked at sort of scientific
machine learning problems from the
perspective of ml but knowing a lot
about physics right so my dissertation
was in liquid state statistical
mechanics
and so there's a lot of models for water
you want this for protein hydration and
so it wasn't icing models near phase
transitions it was liquid state
and um and so
the state of the art then the
centerpiece of my dissertation was
getting a model for liquid water that
was as good as the best existing models
and in addition got on the nose the
temperature of maximum density
and um and that was important you know
for a range of reasons it wasn't clear
you could get that within the class of
parametrized sort of simple interaction
site models
so i'm wrapping up my dissertation and
it's a bunch of things related to this
but this was sort of the centerpiece
and it was at that time that i thought
why don't i try out scuba diving so this
wasn't a total non-sequitur it gets back
to the scuba diving so the point is i
was
the world's expert in the density
properties of water
and so i think it was the last or second
to last semester before the dissertation
was wrapping up
and scuba diving can be dangerous but if
you get certified and i had a very good
class actually
where you walk through the physics of
stuff so if you're down at 50 or 100
feet you can constantly breathe out if
you have a problem and shoot straight up
to the to the surface it's a problem if
you're in a cave or in a boat under a
shipwreck or something so you gotta be a
little careful but you can just
constantly breathe out and and um avoid
bends and you know things like this
and it's just pv equals nrt it's basic
physics and basic chemistry so you need
i took a class you need in water i need
a written exam and i got one question
wrong on the exam
what is that and that had to do with the
density of water
it's you are an expert on it right
i mean the answer is 0.997 in the units
i always used
the units on the test or units i didn't
know you know as force pounds versus
inverse light years or something i mean
it was units i didn't recognize and so
i rec i pulled the only number i i
marked a check next to the only number i
recognized
which um i just recognized from reading
the book was the density of air so it
was a factor of a thousand off so i just
recognized the numeric value but didn't
recognize the units so that was sort of
a lesson
for me in um
so literally the world's acts but i got
the density wrong so this is a lesson in
um
how to design tests that really
extract whether someone's learned
something and so i teach classes now and
that's sort of something i keep in the
back of my mind all right great all
right thank you michael stacy right
yours
that's a long answer to the fun fact
i hope you don't have a second fun fact
question we'll never get no no no it's
all it's it's let's go to the technical
now but that was sort of a preamble
which wasn't a total non-sequitur in the
sense that um
you know i did computational statistical
mechanics and so i was a user of of
linear algebra and a user of
a range of sort of techniques
um and and in the last however many
years sort of developed them in the
context of machine learning
and a lot of
scientists i mean i work in industry but
also like scientific problems
and it's a source of endless frustration
for me so hopefully people in this room
or audience are listening and
will meet me either halfway or quarter
away
so oftentimes what people say is oh i
want to use machine learning for such
and such
and
in my answer being sympathetic to the
scientific problems such and such but
also realizing this is an
interdisciplinary space and different
areas have very different standards i
want to say yeah but i want to use such
and such for machine learning
so you have a scientific problem what
can you do to help me not vice versa
and i think framing the question that
way is sometimes useful for people to
think about because otherwise i'm a
machine learning person and i'm just a
tool that gets buried in a method
section at the back of your paper
and of course the flip side is if i
publish in a machine learning venue i
publish a toy scientific data set or a
toy non-scientific data set and the ml
people don't care about the details of
the data set they want the method
and so what i want to talk about today
is sort of trying to get beyond that and
trying to combine what i'll call
principled scientific models with
principled machine learning models
and so we did a lot of work on
randomized linearity and other things
over the years that really sort of are
very interdisciplinary and oftentimes
the best methods there um
the reason the two areas are in them are
different and sometimes inconsistent you
know area a likes the method because of
such and such area b likes it for
basically an incompatible reason
worst case versus statistical properties
interesting properties machine learning
or generalization versus usefulness in
the scientific domain they can be very
different and so what i want to do today
is to try and sort of lay out you know
it's a toward combining so it's not the
final word but a progress report on some
of the recent experiences we've had with
trying to get you know methods that are
really interesting for machine learning
but mapping in very non-trivial ways to
sort of scientific methodology
right
so um
something that's very common in
scientific problems is modeling um
space and time and so we're going to be
dealing with this
and so we want to be modeling spatial
and temporal behavior
and um
that's something that's not obviously
first class in machine learning right in
machine learning you define features the
data may come from a spatial domain but
maybe not if you're working on
computer vision there might be some
structure to the image but you might be
working on internet ads or something
where there's not an obvious spatial
component
and so um think about what's peculiar
about space and time especially if you
want to be applying machine learning
methods
so um
so how can we integrate domain insight
with data data-driven methods this is
going to be the basic question and when
we ran when we started the
tripods and the foundations of data
analysis institute at berkeley we had a
couple foundational questions just
scalable algorithms and statistical
inference but one of the foundational
questions was how do you combine in a
principled way
domain-driven models with data-driven
models
and so that's sort of the question we
want to address
one thing that's gotten of interest in
recent years is neural networks
and so i'll be talking about two
examples of that but i think the
questions the basic questions more
general than that and we've had results
over the years we've thought about that
so
um that's informed our sort of
approaches here
all right so um
so i want to talk about
sort of two main topics and then i
wanted to
mention a couple other related
developments at the end just to sort of
put it on your radar
um and have me back in a couple years
and i'll tell you about how those
results play out i mean we have a pr i
think i have a pretty good idea
of of uh how those will play out but but
they're sort of um
recent developments that are working
progress having to do with the temporal
sequential properties
i want to talk about two other things
we've been thinking about for a number
of years
the first has to do with um
physics-informed neural networks so
physics-informed
neural networks are a class of models
that a particular group of people have
developed
and roughly the idea is i want to
minimize a loss
like in machine learning and i tack on
domain insight as a regularizer
um
it's it's a special case of what's going
on instead of scientific machine
learning and um and we want to study a
particularly simple version of that to
understand
um what's going on from the machine
learning perspective and in particular
from the optimization stochastic
optimization perspective
um
and what i think we'll see is that we're
going to be able to identify some
failure modes with tying those two
things together in sort of a vanilla way
and i think if you tie them together in
a somewhat non
vanilla way you still have the same
failure modes and they have to do with
sort of
what it means
to have a constraint you know a physical
constraint versus not physical
constraint and as is the constraint a
hard constraint or soft constraint and
these are sort of details of the
optimization
that machine learning methodology
handles in one way and in some cases
physically you need to handle in a very
different way and so the idea in the
back your mind is usually machine
learning constraints are just
suggestions and so you just need to
satisfy them very approximately if at
all
um in a lot of scientific problems
constraints are important if you want to
constrain your energy and you want to
iterate your simulation if you don't
conserve energy
your simulation blows up and so it's
it's it's it needs to be handled in a
much stronger way and respected and so
there's some interesting issues about
the details of the constraint that i
think that work sort of highlights
the next thing i want to talk about
again is um
something that
matters scientifically but also matters
qua machine learning and this has to do
with the idea of continuity in in most
cases in machine learning you do
training and testing on a given set of
data and it's basically discrete i mean
you can put a t there you know and call
it continuous but basically the
methodology the design decisions that
you make
um are discrete and if you want to learn
something like a continuous model how do
you do it i mean oftentimes you said
learn i said you'll specify a set of
basis functions learn parameters for
those basis functions so machine
learning you're really learning
something discrete those parameters you
can fix the basis functions
um you might try and adjust the basis
functions but where does continuity
really enter and so we'll get to that
um
but in the back of your mind before you
get to that ask yourself
you know a version of this question
already appears in numerical analysis
right in numerical analysis
um in scientific computing you typically
think geez i have a continuous pde
but i can't write down a continuous
thing on a computer so i discretize it
and so what does it mean for a discrete
representation of a number to be
approximately continuous so what does it
mean for a
a discrete algorithm a numerical
integrator to meaningfully approximate a
continuous function and so so how would
you quantify that i mean um and so we'll
get to an example of how to do that so
numerical analysis is a range of ways to
quantify that and we'll use some similar
ideas there
so um details of the optimization um
details of what it means for discrete
things to approximate continuous things
clearly both important on the scientific
side but also
um cutting across the way ml methodology
is usually developed
and the other related developments that
will basically be having to do with time
series
temporal or sequential modeling
um
time really doesn't appear in the
structure of of a lot of modern machine
learning it appears in econometrics and
sort of older schools sort of
statistical techniques
but a lot of modern machine learning um
think kernels think boosting think
neural networks i mean
um it's classification it's regression
it's ranking i mean so so time doesn't
really appear as a first class citizen
you sort of graft it on separately if at
all
um and so um can you get beyond that and
so those are these are the things i'll
mention at the end all right
and
um
this is a slightly different form you
usually have zoom and some things on the
side so either interrupt if you have a
question or if there's a channel with um
that you can post comments and i can't
see that but post the comments and and
um
you know either someone can interrupt
during or after with questions i'm happy
to do it either way
all right so let's talk about um
understanding um what can go right or
wrong when you're when you're trying to
couple um machine learning methodologies
and scientific methodology and let's use
these physics and form neural networks
just as an example
um
so physics and foreign neural networks
um are class of models carnegie doctors
and others have developed that it's it's
a nice very nice sort of hello world way
to do a range of things
and they've done a lot of work there and
and i i sort of like them because um you
know i don't it's not the final word and
for some things you want to do other
stuff but but it was a nice sort of
let's call it hydrogen atom for us to
sort of look at
how ml methods and physical methods sort
of might couple together
so the usual approach in machine
learning think think ridge regression if
you want to do that is sort of given on
the right here you have an optimization
i want to minimize least squares or some
loss and maybe i have a constraint it's
an l1 or it's an l2 you know it's a
ridge regression or a lasso constraint
so i optimize f plus lambda g and make
it a soft constraint i might it could be
a hard constraint minimize f such that g
is is equal to some value or less than
equal to some value but the way it works
in machine learning is you you take that
hard constraint you relate it with a
soft constraint with this lagrange dual
mechanism and so you've been basically
minimize f plus lambda g
so the the physics inform the pin
approach does something different you
have a bunch of data points
and i want to minimize the loss on those
data points
but then rather than using an l1 or an
l2 ball the constraint is basically a
linear differential operator i mean on
the left i have a particular example
berger's equations for fluid flow but
you have a linear operator and so it's a
differential operator and so let's just
use that as the physical insight the
domain inside and tack that operator on
as your constraint g although here i'm
using the letters l plus lambda f so
um minimize bunch of data points subject
to a constraint that's given by the
physics
now the question that comes from this
form i mean so you're not going to
status neither of those are going to be
zero exactly so you're already in the
lagrange dual and optimizing this
approximately
now um the usual interpretation of this
as well there's a trade-off you know if
lambdas 1 or 0.1 or 10 you know these
two terms one matters more or less the
fact that there's a lambda here i mean
people might say well i could set it to
be zero or non-zero
um
as long as i stay away from zero
infinity i can put lambda before this or
i could put lambda before this and i
think in a lot of people's mind the
data's primary minimizing the loss and
tack on the the second term as sort of a
prior bias in yourself towards you know
small norm balls or in this case physics
in a lot of physical applications i
think it's sort of reversed and this
constraint the physical thing the
structure the pde matters more and so
you really should think of the lambda as
being over here now of course it doesn't
matter if you think of lambda as
permitting it to be zero or infinite but
um when it's the problem set up and then
if you call black box code
um you can get very different results in
those two cases
so what the pin approach does is adopt
sort of an ml methodology now the first
thing to know for machine learning is
that um
there's a range of typically stochastic
optimizers first order stochastic
optimizer stochastic gradient descent
now vanilla stochastic gradient descent
doesn't do so well
and so you get a range of variants of it
there's um sgd with momentum there's
atom there's attagrad
just a whole zoo of methods and
they all have hyper parameters
and it turns out that in you know the
best variant of sgd for computer vision
it's different than the best variant of
sgd
or natural language processing is
different than the best variant of sgd
for recommendation systems
and it's also different than what what
people would use in pins i mean in pins
often as people would use lbfgs or
something like that that's not what's
used in those other areas and so even
the stochastic optimizer itself
um
becomes a hyper parameter to fiddle with
and so the question we wanted to ask is
sort of how does this behave if you call
any of a range of optimizers with an ml
methodology and so
um the long story short is we see that
this method will work pretty well for
nice values of these various physical
parameters and they'll break pretty
quickly for not nice now you could
criticize us and say well you should use
atom prime or atom coupled with lbfgs
coupled with something else i think the
qualitative points we'll be talking
about about lost landscapes and and um
and the details the optimization would
hold true i mean future work i mean
prove that right or wrong but i think
that'll that when the dust settles
that'll be right
and and the lesson here is you need to
go beyond that vanilla coupling to
extract insight from scientific problems
so this is the tldr and i'll walk you
through a range of examples on some
slides so we investigated pins and we
looked at a range of common problems
convection reaction reaction diffusion
and um
and from the ml perspective they're all
the same they're just some pde that we
want to deal with right of course
scientifically they're very different so
the question is you know we want to
combine in a principled way the two
areas
and so we want to get a little bit
beyond just the vanilla cut and paste
but but we also want to do it in a way
that from the ml side these views them
as sort of um
physical things as opposed to the
universe of other things that it could
be which is you know natural language or
whatever so a bunch of work here on pins
a lot of nice work that sort of informed
what we're doing we're going to
investigate these three i'll walk
through one in a little bit more detail
on the other two in a little bit less
detail so let's say we want to learn
convection with pins we have the
differential equation up here beta is
the the convection parameter in this
particular case you have a nice clean
analytical solution we're going to be
able to compare against we have initial
conditions in periodic boundary
conditions so the loss that i had a few
slides back takes this form we have a
loss which is you know a sum of squares
plus
lambda which is a lagrange parameter
plus call it l sub b which is an l2 for
the you know boundary conditions and
initial conditions so we're not
satisfying this in a hard way we're
satisfying a soft way and now let's call
this with some some optimizer and um
we've interacted with with
pin people they say we'll do this
particular protocol with adam and lbfjs
we didn't know it at the time we
our code's publicly available so do a
git poll if you want to compare against
this we we compared with what we could
um in terms of what was available and
and what we saw is roughly the following
um
the quantitative values will change
depending i think on the specific
optimize you have the qualitative points
i think will be robust to this
um at low speeds at low values of the
beta parameter the pin learns a good
model so on the on the left here we have
the the error between the computed
solution and the correct solution
um
for this convection problem and as a
function of beta you see that error it's
not zero it's actually ten to the minus
three or something so it's not great and
this a lot of these methods seem to
peter out at ten to the minus three or
ten to the minus four for reasons i
think that are probably partially
understood
and as beta gets larger it gets worse
and at some point it sort of chokes and
there's a sharp transition
and um
the exact solution on the right is shown
um for bait equals 30 where you're in
this regime after it's choked and the
predicted pin solution so you get
something very
at early times it satisfies the boundary
conditions right you see here the bottom
matches up to the top
but um beyond that if you have a you
have basically a problem propagating the
information
all right
um so beta equals 10 before you have
that problem you get perfect you know
basically perfect resolution
reconstruction this looks sort of bad
but but look at the scale of the y-axis
on this difference it's a couple orders
of magnitude less than the second third
row so so basically the eyeball test
says the predicted and exact solutions
are the same beta equals 50 beta equals
70 it gets gets much worse very quickly
um
all right learning reaction you see the
same thing it's a different differential
operator
uh periodic boundary conditions initial
conditions loss function of the same
form for small values of rho it's not
paid it's a different it's a different
physical parameter if you're less than
10 to the zero we should probably have
the larger range of row here but if
you're less than 10 to the zero less
than one um you know the quality is a
little bit worse than you saw before but
down at just above 10 to the minus 2 and
then it chokes and has a problem once
you get up above
10 or something
training a pin is going to be sensitive
to the initial value the exact solutions
on the left the predictive solutions on
the right here's for row equals 5 or 10
which is in that regime where you have
problems
you know if you're depending on the
resolution to screen and your eyeballs
you know you get something here so it's
not it's not all purple but
it quickly degrades
um reaction diffusion same sort of
situation here you have a new in a row
parameter but the same sort of set up
initial conditions periodic conditions
loss function of the same sort of form
and um similarly
exact solution predicted pin solution
you just have you know in this case you
actually do propagate the middle region
through in time
we could be better or worse if we vary
those parameters but but it
fails to learn sort of the the full
physics in some sense now this is not an
expressivity problem the network can
learn this um this is a issue about the
optimizer and so the point is you can
say well you should use this optimizer
that optimizer i think in ml there's not
a there's not good theory to guide why
different optimizers perform people
typically we use stochastic first order
methods there's lots and lots of papers
having theory that having to do with how
these methods converge in nice convex
problems very very little that really
provides qualitative or quantitative
insight
into how different versions of
stochastic optimization methods would
perform on realistic cv nlp
recommendation systems scientific ml i
mean sort of problems i think this is a
nice sort of open
class of problems on the ml side
so challenges with pins we started a
bunch of basic things
we saw that coupling these things
together
in ways that would be very natural for
an ml problem had very
um very sort of immediate choke points
and and so there's failure modes and the
failure modes is i mean
i don't want to say we couldn't have
done better on the on the pin problem
itself we can and and you know others
have in subsequent work to these papers
what i want to say is that when viewed
from the perspective the ml methodology
there's these natural failure modes that
that the two sort of approaches don't
impedance match well so i'm gonna i'm
gonna provide some evidence having to do
it that this has to do with the form of
the differential operator
and then i want to um provide sort of
two ways to quote solve this problem
that i think if you're in machine
learning you'll say yeah that makes
sense because that's a learning paradigm
i can appeal to if you're on the science
side you'll say yeah that's trivial
that's what i would do anyway
which again gets to the comment i made
before that the standards of these areas
are sort of very different
so um
if you look at the lost landscape via
say the hessian you know the second
eigenvalues
um if you look at the lost landscape
what we see is something that's sort of
rather unusual from an ml perspective
from an ml perspective if you add more
regularization the lost landscape
typically gets nicer and flatter and
what we see here is that that's not the
case if we add more regularization and
we see it very strongly as a function of
this beta parameter let's say the
physical parameter
that um we either learn or don't learn
as we change that what we see is that
the landscape becomes
much
choppier
and the scale of the y-axis the scale of
the
non-niceness
gets much uh much worse
and so we're adding this this with a
range of other things that i'm not going
to have a chance to get into i think is
arising because we're we're calling a
black box ml method to solve this
and the usual thought is that these
regularizers are nice convex balls and
that's not what's going on here what's
going on here is that these are
differential operators that will have a
non-trivial null space and a range of
other things like that and so solving
the problem exactly quote exactly
or with a reasonably high quality method
like lbfgs versus solving the problem
approximately with a lagrange dual and
stochastic optimization
um is is just very different they're
just very different
and so i think what the state of the art
and pins now would do is run a
stochastic first order method like atom
it's sort of like a temperature
annealing and then run lb fgs and so
they're they're doing sort of an explore
phase and an exploit phase
which is consistent with what we're
talking about here but here um as you
add more regularization um and a lot of
times the lost landscapes gets worse and
i think that's because probably the
non-trivial null space so open question
how to come up with better stochastic
optimization algorithms for constrained
optimization dealing with non-trivial
null spaces that's sort of a nice sort
of question raised by this work
um and so you see that um
similarly as if that was a function of
beta this is a function of uh
was there a question
all right
what's your question i don't know okay
you can go on
so now you know what do you do with this
and and in machine learning off
sometimes the people complain that
machine learners sort of
do an old thing and just give it a new
name and then some truth to that and
some not truth to that so let's leave i
want to leave that discussion aside for
a second but there's two approaches that
would be natural in machine learning and
one's going to be called curriculum
regularization and one's going to be
called sequence to sequence learning
curriculum regulation roughly says start
training the neural network with a
simple ode or pde and then make it
problem harder so choose a nice value of
the beta parameter and then increase it
you know show the problem um
nice data and then gradually make the
data worse sequence to sequence learning
is instead of predicting the entire
state space
you know start at the left and march to
the right
i think both of these things are sort of
the obvious thing from a scientific
perspective and so you might say oh
that's not so interesting
interesting thing here is that
um
a an approach in machine learning to get
good inference to get good
generalization is to do empirical risk
minimization
you know minimize error on the data
points and if your model class isn't too
bad et cetera et cetera you get good
inference that's sort of bread and
butter machine learning theory that's
not what neural networks are doing
because the back prop step damages that
but but you know you can do that so then
if you're doing machine learning neural
networks because the back prop step can
you get good generalization so there's a
lot of work on that
these are sort of column learning
paradigms they're ways to frame a
problem such that if you if you
interrogate the data in a certain way
you might get certain inferential
guarantees
now you might say oh this is the obvious
thing to do from a scientific
perspective but getting that right for
machine learning and
statistical learning theory is rather
non-trivial and so informally you can
think of curriculum regularization as a
little like simulated annealing except
you're not changing a temperature
parameter you're changing the physical
parameter to make the data easy to hard
but this is a hard thing for machine
learning to deal with because now you're
having a change in the distribution of
the data and a lot of the theory doesn't
deal with that so well so
these two approaches are
nice
you know open questions quantum machine
learning here and i think um
if if scientific machine learners engage
this more aggressively rather than less
aggressive they would inform how machine
learners frame their questions to be
more useful for scientific nl problems
so um if you do both of these the method
does better so curriculum regularization
here's the beta parameter you start with
easy values and anneal up to the harder
values um you know you go from the left
to the right so if you do this um you do
you do better so the networks have the
capacity to learn this and if you anneal
the quality of the data analogously to a
simulated annealing but now you're
basically annealing the quality of the
data um you can you can get good results
in the convection problem similarly for
the other problems here's some numbers
to justify that um similarly in the
reaction case you can go from the plot
we had before where it's basically all
purple here the quality is a little less
good and there's some non-trivial
structure that we're trying to
understand but basically you can learn
this
um
um on the bottom right which is roughly
what we had we some of the curvature
properties of this are a little bit
different but um you know you get the
sort of course properties right um the
lost landscape one thing that was
interesting here that we didn't expect
is um the scale of the y-axis stayed
similar
meaning that's a function of beta
but the choppiness got much nicer
meaning meaning that it as we annealed
this the choppiness of the landscape got
better even if the scale of the y-axis
got better and so this has i think um
interesting implications for learning
from non-trivially structured and
non-convex regularizers namely for
example differential operators of these
non-trivial null spaces
if you do the sequence for sequence
learning roughly you march from left to
right rather than learning the whole
state space you march from left to right
and you go from the middle to the right
which is a much better approximation of
the left than the middle clearly
um here's some numbers to justify that
these are the papers this is actually
the first pin paper it's going to appear
in the nurbs which is the top ml venue
next month this is actually the first
pinned paper on machine learning
uh in in a in a machine learning venue
all right so i think pins is a nice
example of things in general but it's a
very simple setup to begin to ask how we
can bridge the gap between scientific
models and and machine learning models
and i think we just identified a number
of failure points that were interesting
on the ml side um you might say oh this
is trivial scientifically because i
would have done this otherwise but um
but vice versa this is things that the
ml people think are trivial that um
scientists spend a lot of time on so i
think coming up with principled ways to
bridge that gap this is an example of
how to do that and i think we opened up
a bunch of interesting questions that
we're following up with
both on the ml side and on the
scientific side
all right so i'm not going to go into
those follow-ups because i want to give
you another example of this
and
any other failure modes and here's one
that i think is particularly interesting
and maybe relevant for a lot of people
who work on
pdes of various forms in particular
um
let's say we want to learn people talk
about learning physics learning f equals
m a and learning i mean what does that
even mean
um what does it mean to learn a
continuous model from discrete data so
the intuition might be geez you know i
have a lot of points i just discretized
very finely and you see obviously that
curve is sort of smooth and so it's sort
of approximately continuous but
probably a lot of you know there's a lot
of mathematical subtleties there
and people in scientific computing and
numerical analysis spend a lot of time
worrying about it so what does it mean
for a discrete model to approximate a
continuous model
so let's go into that so continuous
in-depth neural networks so we're going
to this is going to be
a structured class of models um that's
gotten a lot of attention in ml where
you can vary a depth parameter and in
the setup we have we're going to be
learning dynamical systems and you
should think of this as
a one over time parameter all right
so resonance are a class of models that
have gotten a lot of attention um
machine learning for certain problems
um and roughly what they do is the
following you have a state at um time
call it time t or depth t
that's x of t and i want to go to x of t
plus one and this edge means that in the
model i have a link between these two
states
um and so t plus one might be the same
as t t but i also learned some
difference you know the future state is
the current state plus some difference
and call that a residual unit there may
be stuff going on here that we don't do
or don't understand um but
it's something um
so recent work has pointed out that the
structure of this if you would write
this picture as an equation this is x of
t plus one is equal to x of t
plus a residual
and if you slip a delta t in here
and they don't make it one but make it
delta t that's going to be important we
get to you know it looks a little like a
different discretization of a
differential equation
so um can we slip that delta t in here
is this syntactic form enough
um and the spoiler alerts that it's it's
not no it's it's not going to be like so
we want to do is to come up with a
meaningful way to think about these sort
of continuous problems
so what does it even mean to learn that
when we say resonance learn forward or
representation of a dynamical system
that was an euler discretization
um
so one way to answer it is you know can
sort of have a situation where a
dynamical system is meaningful
so let's look at a few sort of hello
world versions of that and see if it is
is meaningful
um
what you should note is that we're doing
something very different than what's
typically done in scientific computing
and numerical analysis right there
you start with something continuous i
want to integrate sine of x from zero to
pi
i discretize it in a bunch of pieces and
then i do the trapezoid rule or whatever
and i add up the pieces and i get you
know whatever the integral of sine of x
from zero to pi is
um
and if i cut my trapezoid steps a little
bit smaller you know i might get a
better result maybe i shouldn't use
trapezoid i should use a higher order
integrator because i can get the same
quality with a smaller number of
function evaluations that's a very
typical thing
and so what you're doing is you're
quantifying the extent to which this
discrete thing is close to the
continuous thing by a sequence of models
and you say they get sort of better as
delta t gets smaller
um we're really going the other
direction we have a discrete thing and
we want to say are you learning the
continuous thing now there may or may
not be a continuous thing here right i
mean i could be doing a pde
but if i'm applying resonance it could
be classifying images into cats and dogs
right so
this continuous thing might be a
physical differential equation we want
to learn
it might just be that we want to say
we're near a continuous model
because that might provide sort of
capacity control
in in the machine learning sense of the
word and be a good model even if there's
not really a continuous model under the
hood so really going in the other
direction i want to keep that sort of in
mind
so let's say we have a dynamical system
we're going to we're going to study that
and we're going to be um
learning basically a a residual that
says the future is now plus an update
and so we're going to study a training
um
such that um
such that the x of t
plus one or x of t plus delta t is some
function that is the original delta t
plus some difference g let's call it and
think of this as a numerical method on g
and so numerical integrators will
approximate the integral with a discrete
series of applications of this we have
some scheme and so we're going to try
and do something analogous
so the point here is going to be the
syntactic similarity just the sort of
syntactic similarity of the euler
discretization really is not enough
um
to say that that this particular
discrete model is a meaningful
approximation of the continuous thing
um
in numerical analysis and we're going to
apply
those ideas to come up with um basically
a convergence test a convergence test
for a sequence of machine learning
models to say that these models are
meaningfully learning a continuous model
so for a given integrator let's say that
we cut delta t
in half or quarter or eighth which might
mean double the number of layers or
increase the number of layers so it's
basically a notion of time step
refinement the error should go to zero
if you're going to learn something
meaningfully continuous the error should
go to zero as you get more continuous as
the discrete thing becomes more
closer approximation to a continuous
thing in the sense of this this time
step refinement um in addition you know
one
integrator a model a
may be better than model b if the rate
of convergence is faster
and so um
you know the same dx dt with different
integrators that should be able to
substitute different integrators and
they should approach the same solution
at their respective rates for example so
we can verify these things using a
convergence test um and so these these
these the idea of these convergence
tests is critical for a lot of numerical
integration schemes in pdes and
elsewhere and so we're applying it in in
machine learning in a sense
so does do resnet units um satisfy these
properties if yes then we should be able
to take a sequence of models and alter
them in very particular ways and see
them get better and worse in very
particular ways
if no then the model should just behave
in some way that doesn't respect the
continuity properties which is very
different all right so here's what we're
going to do run it run a set of
experiments make a data set with one
delta t
delta t is one right you know it's
whatever it is we're going to train
three models
using g um
and and and then we're going to freeze g
and perform that convergence test
and the hypothesis is that a b and c the
things we had on the previous page
should hold so they either will hold or
they won't hold
so the three models are going to be
forward euler the thing we had before
midpoint which is sort of euler plus
plus you do it a two-step version of it
if you're familiar with midpoint you
know what it is and if not it's a
slightly more complicated a numerical
integration scheme which we could
instantiate in the model where the
residual block has some internal
structure that is a couple residual
blocks with with certain weights
and we can also go to rk4 which is yet a
better numerical integrator but in
certain senses where you have a slightly
more complicated residual block so you
know we have a bunch of residual blocks
that talk to each other in a certain way
and i'll have a picture that we'll put
up like this
and so we'll work
in one case um
for ground truth or we have an
analytical solution another case we'll
look at some error and i'll show you
something but um
for the simple first case let's look at
where we have a ground truth solution
so let's train the models they all
perform well um and so there's a ground
truth which is in blue there's a
numerical euler an orange which does
well but then it diverges meaning just
numerical analysis of euler and then
there's the learned model with the ml
protocol i just gave you with euler and
rk4 and green and red and they're right
on top of the blue you can't see a
difference
um
what you see here on the right is that
well this is two different this is this
space and a position but but you see in
both cases the oil gets worse but then
the ml models do sort of very well there
in both cases all right
so now let's
let's um
oops
let's look at um what if we cut delta t
in half if we cut delta t in half which
is the orange gets better the orange is
the numerical version of euler so the
numerical analysis method gets better
but what you see is the green remember
the green here is the ode oil the
learned neural network the ode gets
worse the ode model the ode net model
gets worse
um the rk-4 doesn't if we go out longer
it may but for right here so this is
already a warning sign that
the numerical method's performing as it
should the ml method's not let's go
beyond sort of one point estimate so
look at the plot on the left so um
what you see here is is in red
when i train at delta t equals zero or
the delta t equals uh is ten to the zero
one
um and then i apply the model at a half
a quarter in eighth and sixteenth two
four six eight
what you see is that the quality this is
log scale on both axes the quality of
the model is pretty good at one so it's
a good discrete model the error is
pretty small
but if you apply it at different delta
t's it just totally chokes this is this
egregious sort of failure mode where it
doesn't pass the convergence test at all
so it really really is not a meaningful
discrete approximation to anything
continuous it's a good discrete model
but not good continuous model if you
apply it to midpoint or rk-4 the model
gets better
sort of gradually as as you get more
time steps going from the left to the
right is smaller delta t
deeper depth
there's two very different slopes and
and before it sort of levels off
midpoint in rk for you get roughly the
expected slopes after that it sort of
levels off where this level's off
depends on the noise properties of the
data and a range of other things
um the plot on the right shows swapping
between integrators let me just not get
into that but you see sort of similar
trend so the point here is that
euler chokes is a good discrete model
but not a good continuous one you can
easily see this by checking the
convergence
test that we put forward midpoint and
rk4 are better
um
and um i'll say a little bit more
the the the main contribution here is
the is the is the uh methodology to
evaluate convergence tests because we
have examples where euler's fine or
midpoint can choke so there's some other
it's not it's not just that oil is bad
midpoint's good it's but you know we can
we can test and we can see
sometimes oil is fine sometimes
midpoints not so the results show that
um
the usual methodology and machine
learning which is evaluating training
and testing curves um does not yield
in general
models that are meaningfully continuous
and so if you're trying to do scientific
machine learning that's a problem maybe
if you're doing regular machine learning
that's a problem too and i'll have an
illustration of that
um having a peek illustrates that
essentially the model is overfitting the
discretization of that time step and so
i think there's a lot of work here to be
done to to evaluate sort of model
qualities that you want to be continuous
in space and time or space or time
um and and you know you're gonna if if
you can you can use that to develop
models or you can use this this approach
we have as a diagnostic to assess if the
model's over fit to that temporal time
step
here's a picture to illustrate the
continuous in depth there's some basis
functions and we have some extensions um
so i think this this is a tip of a nice
iceberg let's say that we don't care
about scientific mission i really just
want to classify cats and dogs
and i want to do it on a cell phone and
i and you have a different cell phone
than me so you have more memory than me
and i'm a cloud provider and i just want
to train a huge model but i don't want
to train a model for every version of a
cell phone that comes out and the point
is for every version of a different
memory structure right i want i might
want models
that behave gracefully as a function of
memory size of the constrained model
so can we use this idea and the answer
is going to be yes so the plot here i
have is roughly the same plot i had
before
except the the plot before has log log
scale and delta t it's it's the way
scientific computing people i think
would present the that sort of problem
this is the way ml people would present
it um there's there's a depth parameter
so this is not time but it's really one
over delta t so it's a depth parameter
numbers a layer in your model there's a
test error they have a training a test
set this is a test errors but this is
the analog of that plot and so you can
now apply this on c far 10 which is
which is an image data set that's of
interest in machine learning and what
you see is that if you use the euler
method we use that fails that continuity
test so here this is images there's no
no continuous model under the hood but
we're hypothesizing it we're saying i
want to work within a class of
continuous models you know euler does
better does better boom it does very
well at depth 32 and then it gets worse
and gets better and gets worse and gets
better it's all over the place whereas
if you use the rk4 version it gets
better better and then flattens out and
so you know if i want to give you a
model and i want to behave gracefully as
a function of depth and i want to be
good good good good oops and then um
good good good and then maybe if i get
down to depth 16 or 12 or something get
gradually worse but not totally choke i
could do that by working with a
continuous model so using this
methodology so i think this is an
example that if scientific ml people
don't engage ml people more generally ml
people just do their own thing but even
just for an ml metric
the idea that we got from looking at
continuous nets useful just you know
even for classifying cats and dogs
so um we've applied this in a bunch of
other scientific ml settings um and and
as i said it's not just that oil are
good
oil or bad rk for good we have a sense
of how this behaves for different
differential operators and more complex
problems and so a lot of this is sort of
work in progress that we're looking at
and let me just sort of in there sort of
time skip over that but just mention
that
um we have some other examples of how
that will perform on on
other types of sort of
continuous models that are more
complicated than that um relatively
simple one we put up
so in the last couple of minutes i just
wanted to mention some other related
developments so what we have is two
examples of where a i think a
straightforward coupling of scientific
methods and machine learning methods
um
has failure points and then you know how
to address those failure points in ways
that are that are non-trivial for ml
methodology but also will yield to
better results um in terms of
the scientific
methodology um so here let me talk about
spatial and
sorry temporal modeling sequential
modeling and time really doesn't appear
much in machine learning theory to first
order into second order there's been
some work and just to put up a few
things so
rnns are a class of models that um
deal with with
sequential data in a certain way
could be time
could be dna sequences but where there's
something that's plausibly a quote time
series you can view rnns as a dynamical
system whose temporal evolutions are
governed by a certain set of
differential equations there's a hidden
state h there's a sigma which is some
non-linearity there's a matrix that you
know couples hidden to hidden there's a
hidden to non-hidden
um an offset a lot of machine learning
people spend a lot of time talking about
the sigma this b
if you're familiar with scientific
problems this is like saying should i is
as leonard jones i told you i didn't did
water way back when is leonard jones the
12 6 potential
that in the early days you know you
could compute a distance squared if
you're cubed and computing the square
root is very hard if you cube that
distance squared you get the sixth term
and if you square that you get the 12
term why don't you use a uh
you know a a 10 6 a 9 6 a 9 5 and a half
and you do it because you're modeling
this for computational reasons this is
like saying a lot of what ml people do
is to spend time should i worry worrying
about the details of it is it twelve six
or nine six so that's sort of like what
this b and the sigma are doing if you're
not familiar with that it's a sort of
weed level detail of the model that
sometimes are made for computational
reasons and sometimes make a big
difference scientifically
so we have a version of a continuous
time recurrent unit that describes a
hidden state evolution there's a well
understood linear component plus a
lipschitz non-linearity lipschitz is is
a way to quantify niceness
and the goal here was to do as well as
state of the art on training and test
curves which is what ml people care
about but really get a more robust model
and so the long story short is these
numbers will justify the former claim
it's it's good compared to state of the
art but i think the more interesting
thing
in general but also for scientific ml is
the this because this the form of this
um you're really robust with respect to
a range of input perturbations some
random and some sort of adversarial and
i think that is very different than a
lot of the way ml theory and practice is
set up but it's an increasingly
important thing just on the ml side but
it's critical on the scientific ml side
um we followed it up with sort of a
noisy rnn which said can we fold can we
use ideas from stochastic differential
equations and and and fold a little bit
of noise into the training process so a
lot of people add noise to the data and
and so on we did it in a very particular
way
um where we could view noise injection
as a stochastic learning strategy to
improve the robustness
and so i'm not going to sort of go into
the details but it's a similar set of
setup in terms of the form of the model
and we're able to do that and apply it
to a range of things this is some
numbers and a picture to justify that
how it performs well on the on on
electrocardiogram application
um theorem
the noise injection is sort of
implicitly giving you a statistical
regularization
we have other results where that theorem
is made in a stronger context this is
actually a more complicated model and so
we do it in sort of a leading order
taylor series expansion context
so um the noise injection the way we did
it you're you're exactly optimizing a
regularized version of the functional of
interest and so that manifests itself
that you actually get nicer results
a more robust model
not necessarily on the training of
testing data that's that's the the error
numbers in this table but if you were to
do this in sort of model space and
perturb it so it's more robust in model
space
um
something else sort of long expressive
memory um go from sort of two time
scales to multiple time scales and so a
simple version of an ode is a two scale
od is given in 21 if you're familiar
with this good if not it's it's it's an
ode with sort of two characteristic time
scales fast variables and slow variables
um
solving stiff od is as hard as you know
probably um you can generalize this to a
multi-scale version and and we have that
and and you can learn sort of on long
time scale long time scale sequences so
these are just things we have in the
pipeline
let me wrap up i think the the grand
challenge here is we want to combine
data driven models and scientific models
in a way that's interesting um
principled for machine learners and for
scientists and um
if you're if you're interested in this i
think this is a nice sort of initial
example of how to do that and i think
it's the tip of a big iceberg there's a
lot more work to be done
um and and if you're not a a um i mean i
work at you know lbl also on this
projects there and as i said sometimes
the way i try and frame it is you know
what can you do for me and even if i'm
interested in what you're doing i think
asking that question is useful because
um scientists sometimes say they want to
just solve scientific problems and
machine learning is just a tool and if
you treat it like a tool machine
learners will walk away and
do nlp or cv or something if you try and
engage them there are non-trivial
problems that if you solve in your
scientific context will be useful for
them and they will find interesting
whether it's example of the of the cfar
or those other examples
and so if you want to get ml methodology
and and
strong domain driven models sort of
cooked into um
ml methodology in a more integrated way
i'd encourage you to you know use this
as an example and extend it but but try
and meet machine learners halfway and
don't just say you know how can you
solve my problem but how can we get sort
of
that's not how numerical analysis and
scientific computing evolved right you
really had to get into the weeds of the
computer and the architecture and when
you had a good two-way discussion there
you had
real advances on the science as well as
sort of on the um the non-scientific
aspects the mathematical aspects so i
think um we're in a similar situation
here
and so hopefully um
hopefully this is how things will evolve
so thanks a lot um for your attention
and if there's any questions i'll be
glad to
stay around and answer them for a bit
thank you thank you so much michael for
the great talk it was very interesting
um okay let's have a q and a session
there's no
question in the chat room so
admit yourself if you have questions
so
my my brief question on page 18
if you go back
[Music]
you nicely draw the the graph of the
lost functions
with epsilon 1 and epsilon 2.
and i was wondering
what are those epsilon 1 and epsilon 2
there's a couple different things these
could be random axes that lead to
eigenvalues of a hessian for instance
you get you get stronger results if you
look at the light at the lead two
eigenvalues of a hessian
we're looking at a million dimensional
loss landscape and two or if if we try
three dimensions so there's no perfect
way to do this so i don't want the
picture to be approved so there's a
bunch of evidence this is sort of a
proof by picture but this is choose
you know either random or in this case
you know
um
axes that that are stochastic estimates
of the lead axis of the hessian
got it
okay
so you you chose like the first one or
two first of all
two uh the eigen values and yeah and so
as we have code at a hessian and pi
hessian to do a range of hessian based
uh
methods and so you know if you're
interested in these sort of
hessian-based methods you know we can do
training
in two times backdrop timeless with
randomized linear algebra variants of
hessians so this is these are stochastic
estimates of the top eigenvalues eigen
directions of that
i see got it oh that's very nicely okay
we have a question from
emmanuel he asked um thank you for the
nice talk curiosity
do you think it is possible to
instead of using a new term in the loss
function
include physics as a as an equation to
be respected between layers of a neural
network
um
[Music]
yes
um
[Music]
people like to include it in a loss
because then
then you're dealing you're optimizing a
loss but one of the i mean one of the
big
changes in ml
in the last 10 years whatever is it used
to be the case that people would say do
a lot of feature engineering and then
call a method
decision trees or ensemble or kernels or
whatever
um
and people shifted to saying well you
know design architectures and give
yourself lots of parameters and and let
the features sort of pop out so you're
shifting it from feature engineering to
architecture engineering
so um
my interpretation of the question i
guess is
um
can you include include layers
that
are more
domain driven or physics driven i mean
in some ways that's what convolutions
are doing they're saying if if you have
an image there's some local geometry so
smudge over that and in some ways that's
what um
what rnns and subsequent developments to
rnns and then attention modules and
transformers are doing in nlp they're
trying to
capture the sequential ordering of
language
um and so
question can you do that in sort of a
more fine-grained way
um
knowing that that i have a differential
operator that's a parabolic or
hyperbolic operator and cook that into
the individual layers or something um
i think the answer is yes i mean a
different thing you could say as i know
that i have strong symmetry properties
and so cook that into the into the
layers so i think that's the answer
that's yes also i mean so for bot and
some people at lbl had some nice results
where they were doing
something that sounds like like that
from state of the art climate modeling
and you know they needed to use these
attention and convolutional models but
not off the shelf they needed to really
tailor it to the
to the science and and got some
non-trivial successes there so i think
that's a nice uh direction i mean i
think how those architectural changes
couple with the optimizers is still a
good question because if you make those
changes you might flatten gradients and
introduce other problems but but the
short answer is yeah i think so
great emma emmanuel um he did thumbs up
so
[Music]
that's great is there any other
questions so you can unmute yourself and
ask questions
i really like the the talk um the the
talk you gave um in a way that
i mean it's you're introducing some way
of looking at some perspective of
looking at the ml and uh
you know physical science um together
you know bringing the um the classical
numerical conversion study
or some continuation method applying the
continuous method in the
main
optimization
of the training of the neural net
so i really like that um yeah i think
that's a good direction and one that's
sort of well suited
i mean it's in general but in particular
if you think about these things from the
problem of scientific machine learning
right right
uh i had one question uh
as you talk about uh where you talked on
some differences between the methods and
the kinds of models and the approach
from a machine learning side versus a
scientific side
um
of course there's some real differences
in the types of models that both kind of
approaches develop um one's more focused
on creating
a model that can be run by a computer
and the other is more of a what can i
publish and study and understand the
theory behind do you have suggestions or
thoughts on the role of machine learning
as maybe fitting somewhere else in our
process
to help us identify or come up and think
about new theories or where there's
correlations and concepts that we may
not be intuiting without the machine
learning approach
um
so i'm not sure exactly what you're
asking
but let me give an answer to something
that might be that or by analogy or
something i mean i think
it sounds like you're saying you know
you're sitting on the science side and
you're saying how should i look at this
and how can i
do something interesting or useful with
this right and i think that's that's a
fair question and i mean an analogy i
mean is
who cares about scientific computing and
optimization and numerical analysis
right
you know but but having a a fixed
infrastructure of support for those sort
of things
and people who self-identify as doing
numerical analysis or scientific
computing
um
and and having them talk to you and and
say i want to publish in my own area
because i like this is what i like but
but you know i'm going to be informed by
your problems you never really get a
feedback loop right and so then they ask
questions that would be different than
if they didn't talk to you so it's hard
to say exactly and and and then you get
i mean computers are done more
do a lot more these days than invert 10
by 10 matrices which was the big use
case in 1940 or 50 or whenever right so
it's hard to know what developments will
happen but i think um
having that sort of in the process
you know is sort of a critical for
feedback loop i mean i think there's
just a lot of scientific questions that
people would ask of the methods that
people tend not to ask in in
machine learning venues where you don't
have that feedback loop
and i think that you know that's that's
um a hard
sort of a hard thing to support
especially maybe for i mean i'm assuming
that you know you guys a little bit like
lbl right it's a big lab and there's a
history and stuff but i think
um
you know having that be
at doe sort of a high enough priority
that you say i'm going to invest in a
head count and these people are just
going to do ml i'm not going to but
they're going to go to lunch with me and
inform what i do and figure stuff out
and it's hard for me to imagine that you
won't have analogous
sort of successes like you saw
historically with scientific computing
um and you know where those would be i
tried to sort of give you some examples
of where i think they might be
the details of the optimization i mean
how you deal with hard verse cough
constraints continuous and
and and i think i mean it's it's useful
more generally right because if you can
if you understand what it means to be
meaningfully continuous in time
um that actually would be much more
useful for just ml people if you're
doing self-driving cars and you want to
understand you know flow fields of lidar
detectors and so on
but some of those light eye detectors
are going to feed back to some other
scientific use cases so i think um
so that seems i don't know if that's
what you're getting at but it seems like
you know having that be part of the
feedback loop
and not not demand that sort of every
time someone has something it's very
strongly tied but having a little bit of
a longer lease there seems sort of
um crucial because there's a lot of
green pastures for ml people to go off
and do right so i mean and some fraction
would like to do the scientific problems
but giving them a sort of a long enough
lease that they can
do that and then feedback seems to me to
be sort of an important thing there um
so i'd say it's more of a structural
thing than do this particular direction
because the ones i laid out may be right
or wrong but that seems to be the
bigger issue if that's what you're
trying to get at
all right sounds good another question
from brian gray talk was wondering from
your perspective what the main value
p i and ns pins bring over traditional
numerical methods since they only
approximately solve the equation since
obviously traditional numerical methods
can also solve the same
pdes um i mean i don't know what value
does the computer have i mean people
thought it was going to be to invert 10
by 10 matrices and it just opened up
lots of other questions
i mean i don't want to get in the middle
of a pin debate some people love them
and some people hate them i mean i think
they're a nice initial result to sort of
bridge this gap and and i don't think to
the final word and they'll improve
things but i don't think the question's
to solve a pde
i mean
here's a question if you have access to
a factor of a million more data than you
had 20 years ago
and you wanted to solve pds in some way
what would you do
i mean if pins is a framework that
begins to allow you to couple to ml
methodology and that's what ml does
right and so um
it's it's not to do a better job on
something someone was doing 20 years ago
it's to do a better job on something
different and that something different
is usually
um where the data is cheap and and you
can apply ml methods and if there's an
impedance mismatch between the ml
methods and the traditional pd methods
you're not going to deliver on the
promise but if you decrease that
impedance mismatch you can so i wouldn't
view it through the lens of oh i have an
old school pde that i wanted to solve 30
years ago and pins will do better at
that you know what what different class
of problems that are
pde related can they solve yeah
if i can add that add that
add something to that uh the pins yeah
if you're just talking about the the
fourth uh solution process of the pde
then
maybe not as accurate as the traditional
method but it it does give us a
innovative way of looking at the inverse
problem uh which
which we couldn't do with the
traditional numerical methods so so
there are some benefits definitely
benefit uh through the pins there
okay is there any other questions um
all right if not let's thank our speaker
today it was a wonderful talk i really
liked it thank you so much michael
thanks for having me
i'm glad that you uh accepted our
invitation to the talk okay thank you
great thanks for watching
and um okay let me
start the record button